black holes are dark matter devouring
balls of gravity most of them are so far
away that we don't need to worry about
them but not this one meet Gaia
bh1 this enormous black hole sits right
outside our solar
system more specifically 1,600 light
years away from us now that might sound
like a huge distance but it's way closer
than any other black hole on record
what's worse we didn't even know about
it until now despite Gaia bh1 being 10
times more massive than our sun we
couldn't see it scientists usually
discover these monstrosities by spotting
the gas that a black hole feeds on these
hungry Giants are are called feeding
black holes only Gaia bh1 isn't anything
like that this black hole is dormant it
hides in the darkness patiently waiting
for the Galaxy to throw at some Cosmic
matter to Feast on but there's one thing
that gave away gaia's
presence you see most star systems in
the universe are binary that means they
have not one but two stars orbiting each
other our black hole neighbor is also
part of a binary star system except
instead of two stars this system has one
star and one black
hole Yeah Gaia bh1 was disguising itself
as a star but even though this
monstrosity doesn't feed on any gas or
matter yet it still couldn't help but
jiggle its star counter part A little
yeah good try Gaia but we still caught
you out there in space there are black
holes a lot scarier than Gaia
bh1 and some are so bizarre that they
shouldn't even exist a team of
scientists discovered an unbelievable
black hole and gave it the melodic name
lb1 the weird thing about this black
Cole is that it's just too massive to be
true okay let's get some facts straight
we know of two types of black holes
Stellar black holes are what massive
stars become when they die they're
everywhere in the universe Even in our
Milky Way galaxy there could be as many
as 1 billion of them lurking around
these beasts can be between 10 and 24
times as massive as our
sun the other type of black holes are
super massive ones these enormities sit
at the center of almost every Galaxy
including our own we don't really know
how they form but we do know that
they're unimaginably gigantic billions
of times more massive than our
sun but lb1 doesn't fit either of these
types at 70 solar masses it's too
enormous to be a stellar black hole yet
it's too tiny to be a super massive one
scientists were scratching their heads
trying to explain this
phenomenon some theorized that it might
not be a single black hole but two black
holes orbiting each other others guessed
that lb1 was born of a gigantic star
that was still in the middle of becoming
a black black
hole well the answer was simpler than we
thought lb1 isn't a black hole at all
it's an optical illusion caused by two
rare Stars orbiting each other it's a
unique star system to
stargaze but when scientists said they
found an improbable black hole well they
were wrong but please how could you
blame them it's pretty hard to study an
object fif 18,000 light years away
mistakes happen the good news is that
lb1 didn't upend our understanding of
black holes after
all now that doesn't mean that black
holes can't blow your mind remember the
one at the center of the Milky Way yeah
it's called Sagittarius A star and it's
as massive as 4 and a half Million
Suns but there's always a bigger fish in
the universe
Sagittarius A star might be the most
massive monster lurking in our galaxy
but it's not even close to some of the
really big players out there like ton
618 this black hole is devouring matter
10 billion light years away from us it's
as bright as 140 trillion Suns so bright
that it outshines its own Galaxy and and
its mass yeah 66 billion times that of
our sun yeah that's right 66 billion ton
618 is horrifyingly
Big when scientists discovered it they
began to wonder if even more massive
black holes were possible of course the
name super massive wouldn't do bigger
black holes any justice so astronomer
came up with a cool name for them too
stupendously large black holes or
slabs yeah and then they found one move
over ton 618 there's a new gargantuan
black hole in
town this stupendously large monstrosity
sits at the center of Phoenix a Galaxy
around 8 and 1/2 billion light years
away from
us it's almost impossible possible to
imagine how enormous this thing is
scientists think it has a mass of 100
billion
Suns that's more massive than some
galaxies out there and it won't stop
growing The Event Horizon of this black
hole at the center of Phoenix a is
unimaginably huge too it has a diameter
of about 100 times the distance between
the Sun and and Pluto if you jumped on a
SpaceX Starship and tried to fly across
this black hole it would take you
2500 years to complete that
Journey yeah we're lucky that this
monstrous slab is so far away from us
that we don't have to worry about it
swallowing our solar system
whole but there are two more super
massive black holes very close to Earth
and and they're on a collision course
with each other okay when I say very
close to Earth I mean 500 million light
years away from us but still closer than
a lot of the other scary things out
there seriously though we don't know
what exactly happens when two super
massive black holes Collide we've never
observed a full merger of super massive
Giants scientists think that they'll
dance around each other for about 200
million years before finally becoming
one but this would be a violent marriage
as the black holes spiral together
they'll send enormous gravitational
waves through space waves so big that
we'll be able to detect them from our
planetary
neighborhood but that's not the scary
part mergers like that happen all the
time and right now the Milky Way is on a
collision course with the Andromeda
galaxy when our two galaxies become one
what will happen to the super massive
black holes at their
centers will they merge too would an
event like this tear everything in its
vicinity to
shreds yeah I bet that's what keeps
astronomers up at
night in the center of our galaxy The
Milky way there is a super massive black
hole feeding on nearby
Stars it's called sagittaria a star and
if a giant gravitational monster slowly
eating the Galaxy isn't terrifying
enough there's another Cosmic
monstrosity lurking around it is it
possible that one day they would get a
little too close and collapse on each
other what would be left of the Milky
Way if they did would there be even a
slight chance that the Earth could get
out of that
safely this is what if and here's what
would happen if a magnetar collided with
a black
hole this monstrosity creeping through
the Milky Way is a remnant of a giant
exploded star but it's not just any
Remnant it's an extremely dense and very
magnetic collapsed Stellar core a
magnetar Let me refresh your knowledge
of
magnetars they're born when a star at
least eight times more massive than our
Sun reaches its expiration date and
explodes in a beautiful
Supernova much of that star is gone but
the dense core of it remains most of
these remnants become neutron stars they
spin very fast usually a few times per
second and they're composed of
neutrons some neutron stars have such
strong magnetic fields that they emit
electromagnetic radiation from their
poles that makes them pulsars and you
can observe them with a telescope when
their poles face the
Earth only a few pulsars develop such an
extremely powerful magnetic field they
become the strongest magnets in the
universe the magnetars
they spin once every 10 seconds but
their magnetic field is a 100 times
stronger than that of a neutron star if
one of those magnets came halfway
between the Moon and the Earth well it
wouldn't be
pretty but would it be as bad from a
distance of 26 light years
away well what I'd like to know is would
a magnetar swallow a black hole or would
a black hole gobble up a
magnetar the Collision of these two
giants wouldn't end up in an explosion
but in a quiet Cosmic merger stretched
over billions of
years although magnetars are incredibly
powerful they would lose the battle with
a black
hole depending on the trajectory of the
magnetar as well as the size and mass of
both the magnetar and the black hole the
magn magnetic monster would be eaten up
either whole or slowly piece by
piece as the magnetar was being torn
apart by the black hole it would be
sending gravitational waves throughout
the Universe disturbing the curvature of
SpaceTime once the black hole consumed
the magnetar its mass would increase and
expand its Event Horizon and thanks to
this expansion more and more stars would
be flung into its dark
density the black hole would be slowly
eating our galaxy star by
star eventually after quadrillions of
years of star consumption the black hole
could gobble up the Milky Way all of
it by that time humanity would most
likely be long gone
anyway something is very wrong with our
sun it's turned into a spinning l
Lighthouse of
death what would make the Sun so much
more deadly than
usual is there any way life on Earth
could survive
this and why would it feel like you're
stuck at the bottom of the
ocean this is what if and here's what
would happen if Earth was a pulsar
Planet many stars go out with a bang
exploding in brilliant
supernovas but our sun has gone straight
to becoming a
pulsar sometimes called a neutron star
you could take this as some good news
the sun exploding would obliterate Earth
and take nearly the rest of the solar
system along with it but now that it's a
neutron star the sun would be among the
densest objects in the universe
and one of about 200,000 pulsars in the
Milky Way shrinking itself about 70,000
times the size it used to be our sun
wouldn't be much bigger than a small
City at 10 kmet across and it would be
spinning very fast if it's anything like
the Pulsar located in the Virgo
constellation it could make about 161
rotations every second
oh and it would also shoot beams of
deadly radiation directly toward the
Earth every few seconds or even
milliseconds okay the first thing you'd
notice would be that things suddenly got
a lot darker our sun would emit almost
no visible light but you'd still be able
to catch quick glimpses of it though
only for the extremely brief moment that
its pulse of energy is directly pointing
at us the sun would now be like a
pulsing Lighthouse at the center of our
solar system this eternal Darkness would
cause a lot of problems back here on
Earth there would be no more
photosynthesis trees would no longer be
able to produce oxygen and crops
wouldn't grow so animals and humans
would be on the brink of mass
starvation but there would be good news
astronomers have found exoplanets
existing in a pulsar's habitable zone so
maybe just maybe you'd have a chance to
survive this run OJ run especially
because the habitable zone of a pulsar
could be nearly as large as a normal
star that would mean it could still be
possible for liquid water to exist on
Earth's surface but this liquid water
would only be able to exist thanks to
our warm atmosphere dropping energy from
the Sun and while there wouldn't be much
visible light there would be a lot of
radiation that's because neutron stars
have incredibly strong magnetic fields
this would cause beams of X-rays and
gamma rays to shoot out from the sun's
poles yeah and this would be very bad
news all this radiation would be highly
lethal in order to prevent it from
reaching the Earth's surface our
atmosphere would need to be thicker
maybe as thick as 1 million times what
it is
today if you managed to pump enough air
into the atmosphere to reach this
desired thickness you'd have to get used
to living with an atmospheric pressure
as intense as the deepest parts of the
ocean it would be like going down 10 km
to the bottom of the Mariana
Trench but you wouldn't be able to get
close to that depth before you'd be
completely crushed before you even hit
the halfway point your eard drums would
rupture and your lungs would fill with
blood and
collapse but you might not need to worry
about this because Earth wouldn't be
able to hold such a dense atmosphere in
place the Relentless radiation would
just blasted away and if enough of the
atmosphere disappeared the liquid water
on Earth's surface would eventually boil
away and that would be the guaranteed
demise of human life on this once
habitable Space
Rock 120 light years away from us
there's an exoplanet that can potenti
potentially host
life it's called
k218b and it's a world you'd want to
visit
k218b isn't exactly like Earth it's more
like a super Earth yeah it's 2.6 times
larger and almost nine times more
massive than our
planet scientists think it could be a
hen exoplanet which is just a fancy way
of saying that it likely has a
hydrogen-rich atmosphere and is covered
in liquid ocean that means that
k218b could be home to alien
life only it would take a really long
time to get there if you were hurdling
toward this space Rock from Earth you'd
reach your destination in about 1.3
million years yeah you heard right
million k218 B has a lot of methane and
carbon dioxide in its atmosphere that's
not exactly breathable air so you'd
still need a space suit to walk on this
world and I wouldn't be too hyped up
about its ocean either if an exoplanet
has liquid on it it doesn't mean that
the liquid is water it could be methane
or ammonia even acid like even in our
own solar system There's a Moon covered
in liquid Lakes but these are me and
ethane legs and I wouldn't recommend
swimming
there k218b could have a pretty mild
temperature for an exoplanet that is at
-100° C you'd find this world incredibly
cold now the most exciting thing we
found out about this world is that it
could have traces of dimethyl
sulfide woot woot well on Earth this
molecule can only only be produced by
living things and that means
k218b could be home to alien life now it
doesn't mean that this life would be
intelligent it could be aquatic or
microbial maybe even complex life if the
conditions for it are just right we
won't know for sure unless we travel to
explore this Interstellar
world now how do we know all this well
we had the James web Space Telescope
look at this distant world and take
detailed measurements of its atmosphere
most of the exoplanets have been
discovered using What's called the
transit method it's when a planet passes
in front of its star and blocks its
Starlight that's when scientists study
the wavelengths around the planets and
some of those wavelengths can tell us
what kind of atmosphere those distant
planets
have the problem is exoplanets are are
really far away trying to figure out
what their surfaces are like just by
peering through even our most powerful
telescopes is not easy some scientists
will argue that k218b isn't a super
Earth at all but a Min
Neptune and that's a bummer because as
you know Neptune is an ice Giant and if
k218b is also an ice giant then the
chances for alien life on this planet
don't look so
good now you don't have a million years
to travel to this world to discover it
for yourself so maybe we should look at
a world that's a lot closer to earth
like Proxima centor
P Proxima centor is the closest star
we've discovered only 4.2 Lighty years
away from Earth it's part of the alpha
centory star system with not two but
three three stars orbiting each
other the exoplanet Proxima centor B
orbits only one of these stars but
you'll still see the other two stars as
bright dots in the
sky this exoplanet is slightly larger
than Earth and revolves uncomfortably
close to its host star luckily that star
is a red dwarf and that's much cooler
and smaller than our
sun which is good news because that
means this planet isn't getting toasted
like
Mercury scientists estimate Proxima
centor B has an average temperature of
about - 39°
c that's pretty comfortable as far as
alien worlds go the bad news is that we
still don't know much about the
exoplanet's gravity or atmosphere it
might be our best candidate to set up an
Interstellar base but it also could have
a harsh environment unsuitable for
Humanity's future home it might even
have an ocean of acid or something
deadly like
that the only way to find out is to
travel there and if proximus and Tory B
doesn't work out well don't worry there
are plenty of potentially habitable
worlds out there like this
one Ross 128b is 11 light years from
Earth it's the second closest
potentially habitable World science
scientists have discovered and it's more
promising than proximus and Tor B the
thing is they both orbit red dwarf stars
only Proxima be's host star is a lot
more active and violent it occasionally
erupts and bathes Proxima B in
radiation Ross 128 B's star is nice and
quiet and even though this world orbits
20 times closer to its star than Earth
is is to the sun it still lies in the
habitable zone because like I said red
dwarfs are way cooler than the Sun and
by Cooler I just mean
temperature this world could have a baly
average temperature of 23° C that's only
slightly hotter than the average
temperature here on Earth I don't know
about you but I could settle
there now we don't know enough about
this world to call it our new home it
likely has lots of harmful radiation
reaching its surface and its atmosphere
might not be breathable but hey that's
not much worse than Mars with efficient
life support systems in place we could
make it work besides this super Earth
might have its own life on it if Ross
128b did have alien life it could be
extremely different from what you might
imagine just think about making the
first contact with an alien species
what would that be
like I mean it could go very wrong too
for one we might not survive the trip to
any exoplanets even the nearest ones so
far we've discovered and confirmed over
5,000 alien worlds 63 of them are
potentially habitable but we just can't
know for
sure
a rogue star is headed straight for our
sun if these two stars slam into each
other it could spell the end of all life
on our
planet How could a rogue star end up in
our solar
system what would this epic Collision
look
like and how much time do you have to
live this is what if and here's what
would happen if a rogue star collided
with the
Sun as the name would suggest Rogue
Stars drift through space they don't
belong to any particular Galaxy or if
they once did they've been ejected from
their homes at some point by supernovas
or two galaxies ramming into each other
whatever it is that sends these Stars
hurtling away from the gravitational
pull of their original galaxies it fires
them off at very high
speeds in order to break free of our own
Milky Way galaxy a star would need to
move as fast as 550 km/ second luckily
our sun is only moving at a mere 200
km/s not nearly fast enough to become
Rogue but these wandering Stars aren't
all that uncommon they may even account
for as many as half of the 200 billion
trillion stars in the
universe and one of them could be headed
toward our sun right
now meet GLE
710 this Rogue dwarf star is on a
trajectory that would bring it close to
our solar system in around 1.3 million
years when Glee's 710 eventually reaches
us it would enter the outermost section
of our solar system the or Cloud at a
speed of about
51,500
kmph it could send the icy bodies out
there flying in different directions
maybe even right toward Earth once it
has reached Neptune the countdown to the
Epic Collision would begin tus 10 years
till the impact with the Sun at this
point Point you'd better just plan to
live your best life while preparing for
the upcoming
apocalypse the gravitational pull of GLE
710 would destabilize the orbits of our
planetary neighbors nudging them left
and right this could go as far as
pushing Earth out of the habitable zone
or it could turn us into a rogue planet
after unceremoniously being catapulted
out of the Soul
system after 10 years it would finally
be getting close to Collision time as
each day passes things are only going to
get worse one possibility is that the
Sun and GLE 710 would merge into a red
Nova this would result in a violent
explosion that would unleash nearly half
a million times more light than what the
sun does right now given the amount of
time light takes to travel from the Sun
to the Earth you would be blissfully
unaware of this destructive explosion
for 8 minutes but the moment you do find
out all that light would likely blind
you in a millisecond and then
immediately fry you on the spot that's
because directly behind this blinding
light would be super hot gas this wave
of heat could be powerful enough to wipe
out nearly everything in its path
bye-bye Mercury Venus and yeah Earth
too our atmosphere and oceans would be
completely blasted away this would leave
our planet as nothing more than a Barren
Rock the explosion would also have
created massive amounts of high
energetic
neutrinos these would be able to to boil
you from the inside out Earth would also
be shrouded in Lethal levels of UV and
gamma
radiation even if you somehow managed to
survive the explosion you wouldn't last
long from the harmful effects of all
this radiation you'd have damage to your
eyes skin and even
DNA now if an alien species was watching
this all unfold From A Distant Galaxy
with an incredibly powerful telescope
they'd see a single bright star
surrounded by an excess of reddish
colored gas and the infrared light Left
Behind from the explosion would be
visible for a long time
after but that wouldn't be the only way
all this could possibly go down there is
a possibility there could be a more
peaceful alternative
yeah if the two stars are moving a bit
slower relative to each other they could
end up merging into one massive New Star
as they orbit each other our sun would
strip Mass from its smaller companion
GLE 710 and swallow it in a process
known as Stellar
cannibalism then this extremely hot and
bright star would be called a blue
straggler though it may sound many times
more peaceful this option would still
likely spell out the end of life on
Earth with our sun now a massive blue
star the habitable zone of our solar
system would be pushed further
away black holes are one of the most
devastating objects in space sucking up
everything around them but there's
another another space phenomenon that's
just as
destructive and it's known as a white
hole now what would happen if these two
objects met in space and fought each
other could something like this even
happen who would
win and what is a white hole
anyway this is what it
and here's what would happen if a white
hole fought a black
hole before we get to our fight let's
see what these two opponents are all
about in one corner of space we have the
black hole this legendary space
occurrence is probably pretty familiar
to
you its signature move is to consume
every piece of matter it comes in
contact
with the white hole you're probably less
familiar
with and its signature move is to expel
energy rather than sucking it
in so with our two fighters having
completely opposite attack
strategies who would
win despite us not knowing much about
our white hole mystery opponent it's
much more experienced at conquering
space than the black hole
is that's right the white hole is a
proper journeyman and has been roaming
space for millions of years kicking butt
and taking
names that's because scientists theorize
that this white hole used to be a black
hole scientists suspect that after
millions of years black holes will
become white
holes and all the energy and matter they
consumed over the years will be expelled
back into SP
space that being said when a black hole
becomes a white hole it might not last
very long so it will need to act quickly
if it wants to pick a fight with a black
hole and despite it being different the
white hole is just as destructive as a
black hole if not more so the matter the
white hole is ejecting moves at the
speed of light so it's safe to say that
the white hole is the veteran fighter in
this situation as opposed to this upand
cominging black hole but how much will
its experience help
it after millions of years of causing
destruction throughout the Universe our
two opponents finally
meet they've battled asteroids planets
and even stars but they always managed
to
survive now they both face their
greatest opponent
yet as these two massive forces approach
each other the black hole will instantly
gain the advantage the white hole will
do its best to prevent the black hole
from overtaking it but unfortunately it
really doesn't stand a chance that's
because the white hole has no choice but
to spit energy at its
opponent although it was able to defend
itself against everything else in the
universe unfortunately the black hole is
its one true
match the mass the white hole is
expelling is also being turned into
energy for the black
hole this won't be a quick battle either
as the black hole can feed on the white
hole for thousands of
years and as it keeps feeding the black
hole is getting larger and
larger and now the black hole is ready
for the finishing blow it completely
swallows the white
hole now that it's consumed so much
energy our black hole is is more massive
than ever it might be as big as the
Messier
887 which is 38 billion kilm
across for reference that's 3 million
times larger than
Earth so if a white hole and a black
hole collided we'd have a massive black
hole roaming around the universe
destroying everything in its
[Music]
path and if if it were anywhere near us
well that would mean Humanity would be
in some pretty big
trouble imagine you're out for a walk on
a lovely day with not a care in the
world the birds are singing and the sun
is shining actually the sun seems
brighter than usual and come to think of
it your skin feels kind of funny it
turns out that's not the Sun at all but
but the radiation and gamma ray filled
light coming from
aazar so in short you're in serious
trouble how did aazar even get here and
what would happen to Earth if a quazar
moved into our
neighborhood this is what if and here's
what would happen if a quazar entered
our solar
system I hope you didn't have any plans
today because the brightest object in
the sky has set up shop in our solar
system so what exactly is going on
anyway a quazar is the result of two
black holes colliding to form a super
massive black hole with a Central Mass
that outweighs our sun by a billion
times when black holes merge everything
goes out of whack the two black holes
begin to consume all the gas and dust
from each other along with anything else
in the
area Okay so if they're eating each
other why are we seeing that bright
light well the material that's thrown
off begins to glow from pressure and
friction resulting in the blinding light
you're seeing if this were to happen in
Earth's
vicinity it would be a result of the
black hole in the middle of the Milky
Way galaxy smashing into the black hole
at the middle of the Andromeda galaxy
which is 2 and 1/2 million light years
away if these two met we'd be looking at
a massive amount of infrared light being
expelled into the universe oh and it's
also a harbinger of death and
destruction too what would happen to our
planet well brace yourself because this
is going to be a doozy quazars throw off
Jets of particles that are so bright
they outshine all the stars in their
galaxies so our sun would essentially
turn into a candle in the middle of a
very bright Spotlight the illumination
from aazar along with all the radiation
it throws off would mess with Earth's
atmosphere the light is enough to
energize particles that make up the
atmosphere and free them from Earth's
gravity our atmosphere would be
destroyed and we really need our
atmosphere it's our protective layer
that keeps things in order and regulates
the temperature without it the oceans
would drop up Arctic Ice would turn into
water vapor and everything would get
much much
hotter in addition to it being
blindingly bright we would have no safe
air to Breathe No plants to eat or feed
animals and there would be no water to
drink life on Earth would be a
wrof this would all happen very quickly
so you wouldn't have to live through a
long drawn out Apocalypse at least you
can look forward to that
but could this sort of Doomsday scenario
actually occur well yes but not for
another 3 or 4 billion years at that
point the sun will be flickering out and
by that time we're pretty sure something
else we've covered on wh if would have
taken us out first so we won't even be
around to see
it if you could teleport the Earth to
any place in the universe what would you
want to look at in the night sky
the bright explosion of a supernova a
black hole passing over your house how
about a nebula what would this gorgeous
gas cloud look like up close and how
would the Earth change if it were inside
it this is what if and here's what would
happen if we lived inside of a
nebula what is a nebula anyway a nebula
is a giant cloud of dust and gas in
interstellar space
they are vast sometimes taking up
hundreds of light years of space but
with all that size they aren't massive a
nebula the diameter of the Earth would
only have a mass of a few
kilog that's because nebuli aren't very
dense and that's why if we lived inside
one it wouldn't look anything like what
you might
expect some 1344 light years away from
Earth is the Orion Nebula the bright
nebula in our Sky it's 24 light years
across and has a mass equivalent to
2,000 Suns if the earth was formed
inside it all you'd see in the night sky
would be this not impressed I know I
wasn't either it turns out it's not that
easy to see in nebula when you look at
the night sky to your eye most galaxies
in the universe don't look anything like
this more like this and most nebuli are
invisible alt together your eyes aren't
sensitive to the kind of light a nebula
produces but look at the image taken by
the Hubble Space Telescope and you'll
see a beautiful gas cloud that doesn't
mean these beautiful images of space are
fake their colors just represent the
light waves that your eyes aren't able
to detect so if you had the Hubble
telescope would you be able to see a
nebula if you lived in one sorry to
disappoint you again but no nebuli are
pretty only when they're hundreds of
light years away they look thick and
cloudy only because you see the
structures of Lighty years and thickness
once you're close to them their light
spreads out so much that you can't see
them you could fly your spaceship right
into the nebula and never even know it
if the Earth were inside a nebula the
only effect you'd see would be brighter
auroras unless the solar wind blew all
the nebular particles far away from the
planet how do we know we're not living
inside a nebula right now simple after
Gathering the data on our own Sun we can
calculate the expected brightness of the
neighboring
Stars if we did live inside a nebula
we'd notice that our star was much
brighter compared to others the nebula
would be dimming the light coming in
from outside of
[Music]
it this is the most powerful object in
the
universe the biggest spinning magnet to
ever
exist it's the cosmic equivalent of a
great white shark but it wouldn't eat
you it would just turn all your atoms to
dust this is what if and here's what
would happen if a magnetar entered our
solar
[Music]
system if you thought neutron stars were
big and scary well you haven't heard of
their more powerful Stellar cousins
yet like neutron stars magnetars are
leftovers from Supernova explosions
they're just packed with a lot more
matter their density is so high that a
single teaspoon of a magnetar could
weigh in at a billion
tons they're also the most magnetic
Stars we know
about we use a unit called a gaus to
measure the strength of a magnetic field
Earth's magnetic field is only about 0.6
G the magnetic field of a magnetar can
be as strong as one quadrillion gaus how
long would it take a stellar monster
like that to rip our planet
apart it wouldn't be the worst thing in
the world if a magnetar was sitting
quietly in our Galactic neighborhood but
if it decided to stop mining its own
business there are two ways a magnetar
could end all life on Earth together
with the planet
itself it could get too close to the
planet you'd start to feel its presence
when it was about halfway between the
Moon and the Earth at that distance a
magnetar would erase the information off
all your credit cards magnetic
strips whatever you do try not to get
closer than 1,000 km from a cosmic
Invader because if you did your atoms
would get stretched out of shape your
bioelectric field would get scrambled
disintegrating your molecular structure
and your body would just
disappear alternative ly a magnetar
could destroy us from much much further
away as if being the biggest spinning
magnets in the universe isn't enough
magnetars can also be affected by
something called star
Quakes star Quakes happen when a star's
crust cracks letting massive amounts of
radiation out into space this blast of
radiation could compress the Earth's
magnetic field and partially ionize the
Earth's atmosphere even from 50,000
light years away
we know this because we've already come
a little too close on at least one
occasion in 2004 gamma radiation from a
magnetar reached our planet from outside
our Milky Way
galaxy in just 1/5th of a second it
released more energy than our sun has
released over the last
250,000
years move that magnetar and its
starquake up to 10,000 light years away
and things would get much
worse first it would destroy our ozone
layer then it would wipe clean most of
the planet's surface along with all Life
as We Know
It the truly scary part of this is that
we wouldn't even know the magnetar was
heading towards us it would be a blink
inyou gun
scenario I won't lie to you there are
magnetars close enough that if one had a
violent starquake right now we'd all get
wiped out very fast
when scientists began their search for
these Interstellar monsters 40 years ago
they didn't realize how many of them
exist out there you might find some
comfort in the fact that most magnetars
don't make it much past their 10,000th
birthday their short lifespan ends with
them becoming neutron stars still dense
and still magnetic but not nearly as
dangerous as a
magnetar but if one of them came near
our solar system well that would be a
story for another what
if black holes are dark matter devouring
balls of gravity most of them are so far
away that we don't need to worry about
them but not this one meet Gaia
bh1 this enormous black hole sits right
at